[Music]
and the clock starts
now did you miss it
it wasn't some bug buzzing by or a weird
trick of the light
you just saw a hummingbird perform
astonishing
aerial acrobatics eat lunch in mid-air
pollinate a flower and then escape a
threat upside down
all in a matter of seconds so let's slow
down the action
and unpack each step in this blazing
fast
feast first up their incredibly rapid
flight
hummingbirds typically beat their wings
30 to 40 times per second
creating the high frequency hum they're
named for
to flap their wings at this speed
hummingbirds have evolved
giant pectoral muscles that comprise
over a third of some species body weight
but the real secret to their fine-tuned
flight
is all in the wrist most birds only
generate lift on the downstroke of each
flap
while using the upward recovery stroke
to set up their next wing beat
hummingbirds however turn their wrists
during the upstroke
changing their wings angle to flap in a
figure eight pattern
that continually generates lift
throughout their wing beats
alongside their massive muscles this
special lift producing technique
allows hummingbirds to achieve sustained
hovering flight
an aerial feat no other bird can perform
hovering lets hummingbirds slow to a
stop
almost instantly and assess scenarios in
midair
then they can take off in any direction
reaching speeds faster than a fighter
jet
relative to the bird's size and since
they can beat each of their wings at
different speeds and
angles the birds can perform incredible
spins and turns
all while flying backwards or even
upside down
of course flying this way can be
exhausting hovering is one of the most
energy intensive forms of movement in
the animal kingdom
and relative to their body size
hummingbirds have the highest metabolic
rates of
all vertebrates this leads them to eat
very frequently often consuming an
average of four meals an hour while
flying
fortunately their hovering lets them eat
at remarkable angles without perching
consuming food that would otherwise be
impossible to reach
using their long slender bills they
reach deep inside flowers and pump out
nectar with their thin grooved tongues
this sugary liquid is a hummingbird's
most important energy source
and a single bird consumes six times its
weight in nectar every day
over hundreds of small meals each of
these
sugary snacks also pollinates the flower
being visited
with pollen left on the bird from
previous meals
that's just a rough idea of what
hummingbirds can do
in several seconds but if we hang around
a little longer
we might see their aerial acrobatics put
to a more dangerous test
hummingbirds keep track of which flowers
they've recently drained
as well as those they plan to drain next
and each bird will fight
ruthlessly to defend this floral
territory from their only real
competition
other hummingbirds using their
spear-like bills and blindingly fast
flight
dueling hummingbirds chase each other
through the air
aggressively stabbing and plucking
feathers the bills of some species
are specialized for fighting with spiny
tips
hooks or even saw like serrations
some hummingbirds employ these aerial
fencing techniques to chase off larger
birds like hawks and owls
but the most extreme fights are between
male hummingbirds
competing for flowers and females
fortunately these duels are rarely
deadly after 15 to 20 seconds one bird
will typically surrender
flying off to seek its breakfast
elsewhere
after all this fighting feeding and
flying hummingbirds sometimes need to
sleep off the day's events
in a mild form of hibernation called
torpa
their hearts proportionally the largest
in the animal kingdom
slow from 1200 beats per minute to a
mere 50.
but when they wake up four to seven
hours later their lightning-fast
metabolism
kicks back into gear with all this
speed and strength it's no wonder the
aztecs revered these energetic birds
as agents of the god of war quitsi
lapoachly
a reminder that immense power can come
in the smallest packages
hummingbirds are clearly excellent
flyers
but flightless birds have some
surprising tricks of their own
learn more about how penguins ostriches
and emus
are living large on the land with this
[Music]
video